nintendo came out today and said uh
they're not interested in offering
twitch twitch is not something allowing
twitch streaming through the wii u is
not something that they're considering
doing because they don't think it's fun
for consumers and we have to say like
obviously this is available on the Xbox
one this is available on ps4 and it's
worth mentioning that twenty percent of
late last year's twitch streams came
from the ps4 that's crazy so I mean is
this another I mean we know Nintendo was
kind of resistant to the whole picking
up new like the new hot thing that's
happening and it which seems to be going
off do you reckon entender can't afford
to be like nope or do you think this is
kind of crazy look if Nintendo doesn't
want to have twitch streams in their
business that's that's that's a whole
different questions it's to me it's like
Reggie fils-aime a said your specific
question of just purely streaming
gameplay well we've got the thing
through is so what's fun about that from
a consumer standpoint what's fun about
that yeah the fact that like his quotes
demonstrate that he like has a
fundamental misunderstanding of the
appeal of twitch yeah and streams and
the let's play community that's more
worrying to me because you know this
guy's Nintendo leadership it's like it's
so clearly entertaining I mean even with
smash brothers there they were
broadcasting here from e3 over twitch
and so he did point out like well that's
different because that's you know that's
uh there's people you know calling
matches and they're promoting the game
and so there's other stuff going on yeah
so they said things like you know mario
kart 8 replays makes sense because you
can kind of see how you went and see how
your friends win and that's the thing
that works i've said that i'm streaming
their treehouse type things which
they're working through twitch this year
they've been super successful and really
enjoyed it but basically what they've
said is that no one they don't think
that their consumers are going to be
interested in seeing just like 30
minutes of gameplay here and there which
is crazy to me because you look at any
Nintendo games and
they are amazing that people love to
stream them off they do they are this so
great and it's it's just insane to me
and it's really like okay yes like is
all twitch streaming good he'll know
there is some really boring really late
switch stuff but like the best twitch
streamers are so entertaining and like
streaming stuff over twitch like this is
how for example like i don't play a lot
of MOBAs yeah but man like watching that
stuff like you know shoutcast it over
twitch and watching people play and just
sort of describe what they're doing if
it's a talented presenter it's
entertaining it's not the service twitch
if you know it just wrap it just feels
like a very myopic view point it's just
yeah to me it seems like riding it off
might be a mistake but i mean nintendo
hood do have a very strong history of
standing outside the block short time
and making it work for them so maybe
this is going to be another one of those
will see and we've definitely seen these
big companies change their minds before
so you know maybe maybe consumer
feedback will see that change but um for
now they're not so on board after that's
all good we'll keep you guys updated
with how this one develops and what
other news comes out during the day